can I take it
[Music]
love it
thank you
let's try that again but with ninja
stars
hey why do we pick a fruit shaped
exactly like my head just stop talking
you're ruining my concentration you're
fine chill he's gonna die
yeah did you hear that what was that
well not that we can do you guys want to
grab pizza
what the heck are those things those are
like little Shreks to me
we've prepared our whole life for this
Leo what happened is Donnie bleeding it
was an accident
so you were baby turtles who made
contact with mystery goo well we prefer
the term ooze but yeah it's like more
like it's just it rolls off the tongue
better yeah
it's nice right
thank you